ever since aristotle we've been told
that we have five senses but it's now
thought we could have around twenty or
more for example the sense that tells
her you're feeling thoughts or cold the
sense that tells you you're out of
breath and the sense of balance we don't
consciously experience the raw
information all these senses generate
because the brain is constantly engaged
in the act of perception the analysis
synthesis and interpretation of all that
data perception can utilize what's known
as bottom-up processing whereby the
brain relies on analyzing sensory data
but certain perceptions are produced in
a different way by top-down processing
instead of relying just on sensory data
the brain calls on past experiences to
make a best guess as to what might be
there in certain situations though this
type of processing results in mistakes
like this you're probably seeing two
different colors here but in fact
there's only one based on past
experience that surface isn't brighter
light a darker than they appear
and surfaces in shadow a lighter the
brain expects that there should be two
shades and so that's what it puts into
the virtual model it's creating this
top-down processing accounts for a
number of human perception traits we
very often see faces because we're
hardwired to tune into them the fact
that we're all living in our own virtual
recreations of the world is revealed
most sharply by cases of people with
malfunctioning perception known as
agnosia it's a general term that covers
many different conditions what they all
have in common is that the senses are
still working perfectly the brain is
receiving the same information it always
did but its ability to process interpret
and recognize is damaged someone's
suffering from prosopagnosia for example
has serious difficulty recognizing
people by looking at their faces but
could still recognize them instantly
from the sound of their voice in extreme
cases sufferers can't recognize their
own image in a mirror a person with a
kin atop seer is able to perceive
objects normally when there's
Dyl but can't recognize or make sense of
anything that's moving when someone with
auditory verbal agnosia hears words they
just hear meaningless noises so they
can't have a conversation but it's only
the hearing of words that's affected
they can still talk read and write so
our ability to navigate the world is
entirely dependent on the complex
mechanisms which interprets all the
noise our senses make and give it
meaning or as the famous neurologist
Oliver Sacks put it every act of
perception is to some degree and acts of
creation thanks for watching don't
forget to subscribe and click the bail
to receive notifications for new videos
see you again soon